he is the pot-stirrer he's Chris Sims
pro football talk live co-host former
NFL quarterback and Chris Jones just now
you know lo and behold I start to you
know go to Pro Football Talk and read
down some stories and then I go wait
what's this Russell Wilson rumor and and
did the rumors start with you Chris that
the Seahawks were entertaining the idea
of trading him to the Cleveland Browns
two years ago well I do believe it
started with me or you know I don't know
if it started in me and again it loosen
it this is something that I know that
this is not a rumor this is this is
something that I found out about I'm
gonna say not long after the 2018 NFL
Draft from some people close to the
situation and then had it confirmed on
the other side by the other team
involved in it to where you know I meant
made a mention of this during last
season Dan and it got no traction I was
like damn I just let out some breaking
news nobody and then it just came out
organically again here this past week we
were talking about untradable players
and what we call PFT ot with Mike Florio
and you know we went Russell Wilson is
one of those untradable players and I
brought it up again I said you know hey
the rumors out there are the things that
I understand I shouldn't say rumor what
I know is that yes there was talks a
little bit between Cleveland and Seattle
and Cleveland giving that first pick of
the draft for Russell Wilson you know I
don't know who struck up the
conversation I would imagine it was
Seattle I mean you know makes sense
again Seattle they were debating on did
they want to make Russell Wilson the
highest-paid player at football and I
think also added to that hey they have
an incentive to build the team the way
they did originally with Russell Wilson
they saw hey if we can get a quarterback
on a rookie contract and build it
through our running game in our defense
that was successful them one time around
already before so I just think you know
it was something that was thrown out
there I don't know how serious it ever
got but I do know that that was a very
real conversation and I understand the
philosophy behind the Seahawks and I
agree with you I mentioned that if you
can start over again at that position
and build your team like they did when
they had the Legion of boom that makes a
lot of sense the biggest question I have
is
who was Seattle going to take with that
number one overall pick Chris this is I
don't know this for sure okay like a but
I've been led to believe it was Josh
Allen that's that's what I was led to
believe that Seattle had their eye on
that would make sense soon because he
has a little of that Russell Wilson ish
quality right where hey obviously it's a
little raw still with Josh Allen but got
some big-time ability and I think they
probably looked at it like hey we can
get this guy to hand the ball off take a
few deep shots down the field
he'll scramble and make a few plays
every now and then so that makes sense
but I can't confirm that aspect of it
Dan I don't know that for sure I think
Russell Wilson ends his career with
another team what do you think I
wouldn't be shocked I I think that's a
very real possibility you know
especially you know a Pete Carroll and
John Schneider are still there I mean to
the point that you made just a minute
ago I think they have a true belief than
that and honestly Dan I'm not so sure
the NFL is not gonna go this way a
little bit anyways you know well who are
the Rams negotiating against the game
Jared Goff thirty three point five
million dollars there's some of these
other contracts that are being thrown
out there they're negotiating against
themselves and with the influx of talent
we see at the quarterback position every
year now and football being so popular
for so long and our best athletes want
to play quarterback
I wouldn't think at some point the
quarterback market is gonna come down to
reality a little bit to me it's gotten
crazy you know some of these
quarterbacks are making eight nine times
more money than some of the best players
that are also on their team and I wanted
to say you know Jared Dolph is not eight
times better than you know Robert Woods
who plays wide receiver for the Los
Angeles Rams yeah I'm with you on that I
never understood that the next guy up
does it deserve right to be the how did
the owners the owners finally got around
to saying we're not going to give
guaranteed money to you know first-round
draft picks we'd give you 50 million
dollars to Sam Bradford who hadn't
proven himself to me it was crazy
they finally you know got slotted and
you know made some sense here at what
point do the owners just say we're not
now I know that sounds collusion
probably is but we're just
not paying the next man up he's not
gonna be the highest-paid quarterback in
the game yeah I agree I have this
conversation with my coach friends all
the time did and I think they do they
look at owners and you know some GM's a
little bit to go like hey well at what
point are we gonna draw a line in the
sand you know like nobody on the edge of
a Dior let's nobody should the next guy
up right and let's just say what errand
Donald like I don't care if he's the
next guy up but he's really good
nobody's as good as Aaron Donald so
nobody should be paying more than that
on the defensive side of the ball until
they can claim they're better than Aaron
Donald and that's the same thing on the
offensive side of the ball you know I
know it's gonna be Patrick my homes here
soon at some point but like to me you
know hey dak Prescott I love that
Prescott Carson went hey I love him too
but like Aaron Rodgers and Russell
Wilson should be the market setters and
nobody gets paid more than those two at
the position and so you prove that
you're better than that and deshaun
Watson in the homes are very close to
doing a tour my homes already has and
they will get paid but to me those are
the only guys that should jump that but
that's part of the problem with dak
Prescott negotiations here is hey what
we want to get paid and we don't want to
sign a deal where we're gonna be
embarrassed by what deshaun Watson gets
and Patrick mahomes get and he's not in
Patrick mahomes category and you can
make the argument he's not into Shawn
Watson's category but if you keep saying
hey I I want I want to be the next guy
up but don't don't embarrass me when all
of a sudden these other guys get their
contracts here I'm also curious what
happens to the quarterback after Patrick
mahomes
what is he asking for well exactly right
I think that might be I think mahomes
has a chance to kind of blow the market
you know into another stratosphere to
where that might happen like to what
you're talking about
that next guy up I think there might be
a line drawn in the sand that finally
says no let's get real you're not
Patrick mahomes whoever you are and
we're not gonna tell you that much money
I'm with you because what are we gonna
do start getting into like forty five
forty eight million dollars a year for
the quarterback position here in the
next two years because I would expect my
homes get something with in the low 40s
near year type average when
sigh we're talking to Chris Simms pro
football talk live co-host the story
with James Harrison the Steelers in Mike
Tomlin did Mike Tomlin handymen envelope
full of money was it a check did he
write out a check
did he pay his fine when he hit the
Cleveland Browns wide receiver here is
he it was he joking a little bit I don't
know I I don't know what to make of this
Chris because he's put Mike Tomlin why I
think he's trying to compliment
Mike komlin SBI a player's coach and
he's got your back ultimately he's put
him in a pretty delicate situation here
what do you do if you're the NFL I the
NFL is in a tough spot here there's no
there's no doubt about it
and I'm sure that they're gonna probably
try to take some action I would think
you know I don't know what that would be
some sort of fine on the Pittsburgh
Steelers or maybe Mike Tomlin
but yeah James Harrison you know I agree
with you I think he was trying to show
something positive about Mike Tomlin and
it backfired and now it makes the
Steelers of my time and look not that
good
let me here's the simple reality of this
situation I don't give a damn I'm glad I
hope Mike Tomlin did pay his fine who
the hell cares
this has been going on in the NFL since
the 80s I was on teams where I saw this
happen
not necessarily coaches pan but players
who are making a lot of big money oh
this guy got you know a huge fine from
the hit and if the defensive guys
thought I it wasn't that bad and we like
to play that style they pony up some
money and help that guy out to pay that
fine so it's a very common thing for
this to happen in the NFL I mean I know
Joe Montana did it back with the Kansas
City Chiefs with Neil Smith I've heard
him tell that story so this is something
that goes on it's just the first time I
think we've heard a head coach being
implicated and yeah you know my comments
in a tough spot here yeah I think Sean
Payton would be really interested in the
Cam Newton phenomenon I I don't know if
any everybody has been this interested
in Cam Newton for a long time but it
feels like every talk show host every
analyst somehow has this newfound love
in seeking out information by afternoon
like we we really we're you know
what it is though and we know what's
behind the curtain it's like this is a
great talking point Cam Newton is a
great talking point I don't know if
people really care if he doesn't go to
the Patriots I don't know if anybody
really cares in our business about Cam
Newton that way if he goes to the
Patriots now we have talking points
again for another couple of weeks what
do you think well I'm not gonna happen
yeah yeah you know I don't know and I
don't think the New England Patriots is
going to happen I don't I just I would
be shocked you know just my history of
knowing New England being there knowing
Josh McDaniels and playing for him in
Denver they're very big into hey this is
we're framing our team in the off season
and this is our quarterback and we're
framing an offense around him and for
him to be the leader of our football
team and all those things to where I you
know I just don't imagine them going
down that road with Cam Newton and
opening up that can of worms of Siddim
burs Cam Newton and all those things and
also I don't think New England's
necessarily built for Cam Newton's skill
set either but I'm fascinated by Cam
Newton too because as we all know right
I mean when he's healthy he's a special
football player and right now he's it
looks like he's gonna be relegated to be
in a backup quarterback and my big thing
is Danis but you know who the hell's
don't even want to sign him as a backup
quarterback because he's a threat yeah
there's only gonna be certain
quarterbacks that can handle Cam Newton
looking over their shoulder every day in
practice and everything like that and I
think that's truly like mahomes Aaron
Rodgers maybe Russell Wilson deshaun
Watson they're gonna be like okay yeah I
know you throw rifles all over the field
look at my rifle zing zing zing and they
won't be threatened by it but a lot of
these quarterbacks I think Dan this will
be a huge issue and then it can just it
can disrupt your team because when you
walk off the field every day players in
the locker room gonna go damn but you
see cam maybe we should start him and
that will divide a locker room in a
hurry so that's really where it gets
interesting
could you see Pittsburgh bring him in uh
you know again it's a name I've thrown
out there many times
IIIi I think that is a correct marriage
because you know I think we're getting
down here to the end with Big Ben I do
and the elbow thing would concern me the
way they're back
the quarterbacks late last year would
concern me and I think they're a team
that's you know a borderline Superbowl
caliber type football team so you get
Cam Newton in there for an insurance
policies policy to Big Bend let alone
hey maybe this is Big Ben's last year or
something like that maybe then the rains
get handed the camp after that makes
sense I don't know do you think Big
Ben's one of those guys that can handle
that that would be a question for me he
couldn't handle Mason Rudolph being
drafted hey it's great to talk to you as
always we appreciate your time thank you
Chris hey thank you happy birthday and
how dare toddlers at Texas A&M t-shirt
when I come on I mean what the hell is
that
I was completely unintentional I was a
little rude well shirt from the from the
closet there but then I realized you're
a long horn and that's not cool I'm
gonna give you you're going into a
headlock you know you know what happened
Chris as Todd gave the horns down oh is
that right yeah I saw it when it came it
whoa thank you Chris thank you buddy
weekend that's Christian ball talk live